docteur jean-luc fanon bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président de l'association
sauvez la santé en martinique créé en
janvier 2018 donc l'intitulé dit tout un
voilà il s'agit pour vous de vous mettre
en action pour sauver la santé publique
en martinique alors on vous a invité
dans ce ca au caddie spécial élections
municipales et communautaires pour voir
quels liens je vous avais justement dans
l'activité de votre association avec ce
type d'entité alors il n'y a pas une
commune ici où se trouve un
établissement hospitalier qui n'ait été
confrontés à de graves difficultés
budgétaires et en moyens humains aussi
ces dernières années même le plus récent
en date en construction celui de mangot
vulcin au lamentin a connu quelques
affres alors de ce point de vue quel
regard vous posez sur cette situation
d'abord vous le médecin que vous êtes et
le président de cette association sauver
la santé en martinique jean luc mano
alors c'est vrai que les questions de
santé et les questions sociales sont
plus que jamais où devrait être plus que
jamais au coeur de des questions de ces
municipales les maires et en particulier
à travers l'association des maires nous
ont toujours accompagné dans nos actions
et nous ont soutenus sans sans aucune
réserve et nous pouvons les remercier
pour pour 7
cet apport dans le combat que nous avons
mené pour sauver la santé alors sauvé la
santé oui public mais aussi libéral par
ce fait sur ces deux c2 ces deux entités
sont intimement liés et ont besoin
l'une de l'autre à ce stade de notre
échange
trouvez vous que ce thème ce sujet a été
prégnant pour lors de la campagne au
moins pour le premier tour de ces
élections municipales et pour les
communautés d'agglomération alors quand
on écoute les discours des candidats ou
des anciens maires ou quand on lit leur
profession de foi
c'est vrai que les questions de santé
sont abordés plus tôt en fin de en fin
de page ou voire pas du tout pas du tout
abordé notamment pour les nouveaux
candidats or la santé est un des piliers
de la société martiniquaise et on
n'imaginerait pas la martinique
fonctionner sans eau ou 100 ou sans la
sara et et bien imaginer surtout dans la
situation d'épidémie laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui qu' il n'y que nous
n'ayons pas de recours de santé c'est à
ce moment là souvent que les
martiniquais se rendent compte que ils
ont besoin de médecins ils ont besoin
d'un hôpital pour pouvoir assurer des
soins de qualité
avez vous réussi à établir au moins avec
quelques maires ou quelques
municipalités
est ce qu'on appelle un véritable y en a
je sais que votre association a fait une
sorte d' un petit peu un tour d'un tour
de l'île à un tour des communes je sais
pas si vous avez fait les 34 mais enfin
vous alliez comme ça communiquer au plus
près sûr d'abord
le constat l'état de la situation grave
et puis inciter finalement les uns et
des autres à se mobiliser quoi chaque
administré et est-ce que de ce point de
vue justement votre relation était plus
poussée avec certaines communes que
d'autres alors il est certain que
d'abord effectivement nous n'avons pas
fait les 34 communes mais on a fait les
principales c'est vrai que l'accueil des
maires a toujours été extrêmement
favorables ils nous ont ouvert les
portes de leur mairie organisé avec nous
ses rencontres avec avec leurs
concitoyens et et ont été souvent
présents pendant pendant ces rencontres
qui ont eu ou certaines beaucoup de
succès notamment celles comme avions
réalisé ici à fort de france où on a été
obligé de fermer les portes parce qu'il
y avait trop de monde
je pense que les questions de santé
intéresse réellement les martiniquais
intéresse les édiles par contre ce n'est
probablement pas aujourd'hui au coeur de
leurs de leur motivation mais c'est
probablement de notre faute nous n'avons
pas été assez c'est exigeant vis-à-vis
d'eux mais je pense qu'on fera continuer
ce travail mais en même temps votre
interlocuteur principal
il est essentiellement l'état un peu la
ctn qui a une partie de l'aspect social
on va dire de la santé est quoi un
sociales liées à la santé
mais par exemple s'agissant de départ
d'un la ctm est impliqué mais c'est
surtout l'état votre interlocuteur en
termes de moyens alors qu'est ce que
vous attendez des mairies des
municipalités des alors il est
conseiller communautaire de ce point de
vue là des maires une sorte de soutien
vraiment affiché de lobbying
d'intermédiaires politique vis-à-vis de
exacte de son interlocuteur quel état il
faut rappeler que les maires ont un rôle
fondamental en matière d'action sociale
qu'ils peuvent jouer de manière
individuelle certes il y joue la plupart
de ces rôles aux côtés de l'état et de
la ctm notamment à travers leurs centres
communaux d'action sociale mais ils ont
la possibilité de mettre en oeuvre des
actions sanitaires et sociales qui leur
sont propres
que ce soit dans le domaine de l'enfance
création crèche de micros
rech que ce soit dans le domaine des
personnes âgées alors pas tant dans la
création l'établissement qui relève plus
de la cité mais et de la rs mais ils
peuvent être porteurs de projets mais
aussi je la dis les bâtiments dans les
hôpitaux dans les communes sont toujours
pour la plupart des habitants comme
dirait des bâtiments d immeuble
dépendant de de la mairie passe passe
pas forcément pas forcément ça dépend
beaucoup qui dépend de qui sont dans la
propriété et la ctm et mais beaucoup
sont des terrains qui sont mis à
disposition à la ces comme exemple de
mango fut 5 vous citiez vols intérieurs
par exemple sur sur une des actions que
font les maires en direction des
personnes âgées par exemple c'est tenir
à jour un registre des personnes
vulnérables notamment en cas de plan d'
alerte ou d'urgence on imagine un cycle
un séisme nous avons travaillé avec
certaines communes depuis des années sur
sur ses projets sur ses plans donc sur
sur ses actions à cet aspect aussi de
mon dirais-je sanitaires en cas de
risque majeur c'est ça
après un cyclone les mairies ayant ayant
mis à jour ce registre s'inquiète par
exemple parce que le téléphone ne
fonctionne plus d'aller s'assurer de la
santé
des ces personnes âgées c'est vrai aussi
en ce qui concerne les personnes en dix
ans en situation de handicap également
qu'ils peuvent avoir par exemple la
création de places gratuites réservées
aux personnes en situation de handicap
relève de relève du maire tout ce qui
relève de la désertification médicale
alors justement est ce que votre
association s'en est saisi de cette
question là alors chez nous on parle
plutôt d'un désert médical puisque grand
une petite île notamment le nord le nord
de l'île vous en préoccuper a sauvé la
santé en martinique
alors oui à travers c'est là c'est
plutôt delà de la compétence de la rs
ici en martinique qui s'est plutôt en
paris de ceux de ce sujet et qui a fait
plusieurs expériences notamment de
création de centres médicaux dans le
nord pour l'instant ces expériences sont
pas très positives puisque on a du mal à
maintenir mais c'est une question
éminemment citoyenne aussi parce qu'on
entend les uns et les autres s'en
préoccuper et voir s'en plaindre dans le
nord à juste titre il ya cinq communes
non martinez qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant
il faut savoir que aujourd'hui beaucoup
de beaucoup de martiniquais qui dont le
médecin
arrête de travailler pour des raisons
multiples ne retrouve pas de nouveaux
médecins puisque saviez que vous deviez
absolument avoir un médecin référent et
que sinon vous payer une taxe
supplémentaire à chaque consultation et
ben on a levé cette obligation là parce
qu'en réalité aujourd'hui
une fois sur deux cantons quand vous
cherchez un médecin et un médecin
référent et bien vous n'aurez pas de
réponse parce que aujourd'hui les
médecins libéraux sont saturés et ne
prennent plus de nouveaux malades
alors on arrive au terme de notre
entretien
dr jean-luc fallon président de
l'association sauvez la santé en
martinique
quel est votre demande principale votre
souhait peut-être votre action aussi
principal pour les prochaines a vendu
les prochaines années je veux dire
puisqu'on se situe dans la mandature si
vous voulez municipal et communautaire
quoi en gros pour les cinq six
prochaines années
alors y rappeler à tous nos concitoyens
que le maire est un personnage
incontournable en termes de santé outre
le fait que dans les communes où il un
établissement il est souvent président
du conseil de surveillance
mais il y là il les marges aussi dans
des eaux conseil de surveillance de la
rs de l' agence régionale de santé de la
martinique
or les questions de santé vont devenir
de plus en plus prévenante notamment
compte tenu du vieillissement accéléré
de notre population et ce sujet majeur
qui au delà de l'actualité épidémique du
coroner au virus dont on aura oublié
dans six mois
malgré tout le battage médiatique fait
autour par contre la prise en charge de
la santé en martinique restera un sujet
majeur
avec cette particularité que nous sommes
un isolat géographique nous sommes tout
seul au milieu de l'océan et que nous
n'avons a tenu à ne pouvons nous appuyer
que sur nos ressources propres et de ce
point de vue donc votre association
continuera à militer à s'activer et vous
continuerez à rencontrer bien sûr les
maires mais l'ensemble dès élus de la
martinique de ce point de vue là pour
défendre une cause collective soit une
cible général une cible particulière
pour pour la santé et la cohésion
sociale merci jean luc fanon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans cette
émission réalisée par paul eric tout ça